hi everyone my name is Mathias Ivana
from UCLA
I'm an assistant professor in the David
Geffen School of Medicine at Mesa rate
and the Semel Institute for Neuroscience
and educators today I'll be talking
about branding recording simulation of
real-world episodic memory so of course
memory disorders are a huge problem
today and in several cases such as
Alzheimer's disease that most people are
aware of where we have over 5.8 million
affected in the United States alone with
chilling annual worldwide costs and
increasing of course there are also
memory impairments in patients who have
had traumatic brain injuries epilepsy
and various other neurological and even
their psychiatric conditions for example
in post-traumatic stress disorder where
here the memories traumatic memories are
you know wanting to be suppressed in
this case where as an Alzheimer's
disease you know it's an issue of
amnesia and forgotten memories that
episodic
episodic in nature and personal so of
course these rates of Alzheimer's
disease as I mentioned are increasing
over the next thirty years where the
costs are also increasing in addition to
the number of people affected the areas
of the brain that we know are implicated
and disorders of memory are in the deep
brain areas and the area called the
medial temporal lobe and we know this
from decades of research working with
many studies but in addition to patients
rare patient studies such as this one
here patient HM who had epilepsy and
surgically had his bilateral so two
sides of the medial on the lovely loot
you can see an MRI if there's on the
left-hand side compared to unaffected
individual where those structures are
still intact
now each M was unable to form memories
for new everyday events and this type of
memory known as episodic memory is one
of the first to be affected in patients
for example with Alzheimer's disease
that are important within this medial
temporal lobe you can see on the right
if you look at a side view the brain
these regions include an area called the
hippocampus and enter Lionel cortex now
each one had these areas removed as well
as some additional adjacent areas but we
now know that these areas are very
important for being able to form
memories or events in your life I about
eight years ago we published a study
showing that if we used electrical
stimulation delivered to this internal
area which is thought to be the major
input into this entire circuit for
memory was sufficient to enhance memory
in a small cohort of patients who had
electrodes already implanted into those
areas for valuation without epilepsy
now we've since followed up on this
study and found that in these patients
from the deliver electrical stimulation
that's very very low to the in where the
participant is unaware that it is being
delivered you can see an enhancement of
memory in those areas but the location
of that electrode stimulation matters
and it turns out that a few millimeters
off can make all the difference where
you see here an increase in the purple
of memory performance when the
simulation is in an area called the
angular bundle which is thought to be
the white matter area of this internal
area and the post here on the left you
see gray matter stimulation was not
sufficient to show any kind of change in
their memory scores this was all within
the same participants so in some trials
they the images or the stimuli the
participant was trying to learn
stimulation was delivered either to a
gray matter area in the entire area or
into a white matter area and it turns
out this white matter area which
consists of the connections between this
area and the data campus was the
important key region and this just shows
you single participants each line
showing a participant with on the right
side in purple showing the right sided
stimulation and a positive slope
indicates that memory was improved you
can see although
one participant showed an improvement
with improvement in memory with
stimulation now one thing to note here
was that the electrodes were placed in
internal white matter area and we wanted
to see whether this was true for other
types of memory tasks not just learning
of individual cases so we did a series
of tasks where participants had to learn
images of objects here in bicycles or
people or face name pairs and we saw
that the location of the stimulation
mattered in all of these cases such that
if the stimulation was to the right side
in the white matter of the entire area
you saw an improvement in memory so
shown in purple hours you don't see this
effect in others the other various which
is the gray matter here shows just an
example of where these electrodes are
placed if you look at an MRI scan
straight ahead close you where the
little red dots are the location of
stimulation and shown here is an example
on the top where the location is in gray
matter of the n-terminal area or cortex
and the bottom is in the white matter
again if you look across all of this
data it cost dozens of participants you
see the location matters in that the
right sided white matter seems to play a
role in enhancing these types of memory
now all these tasks the participants for
learning images on the screen on a
computer screen whether they be faces or
objects or in another task that I'm not
showing here words whether this type of
memory really translates to the real
world when you're learning about events
in your life what you had you know at a
dinner party last week who's there all
of these types of information that
you're learning on a daily basis whether
this type of finding can translate to
the real world
is unclear because we don't test a
real-world memory in the laboratory we
usually test memory for these
two-dimensional images on a computer
screen now a lot of the work that's been
done in the field of memory has been
done in Roman studies where actually the
Nobel Prize was awarded to three
individuals in 2014
for the discovery of brain cells that
may be implicated in memory episodic
nothing and the way that they study
memory in rats no mice is through
spatial navigation so we have animals
run around and it means while these
cells are being recorded and the finding
that won the Nobel Prize was that there
are placed cells in the hippocampus and
grid cells in the employment cortex that
will fire when animals in particular
locations across the environment play
cells of the mate as the name suggests
respond when an animal is in one
particular three squares grid cells fire
in a grid-like pattern where you see
here a couple examples where there's
this nice repeated pattern across the
circular environment that looks like a
grid and it's a hexa drugged hexagonal
grid that has a nice 60-degree geometric
pattern to it now these cells are found
in this area that we know is implicated
in episodic memory that's early affected
in Alzheimer's disease and the other
finding that's important here is that
there are theta oscillations or brain
activity waves that occur about eight
times per second you can see one from
the rat down on the bottom and these are
very tightly coordinated teams play
cells in grid screen cells and are
thought to be important for learning and
remembering these episodic type memories
that in the case of animal studies is
necessary for spatial navigation as I
told you before you know the way we
study episodic memory in humans in a lab
is to show them two-dimensional stimuli
we have not been able to replicate these
finally using rats because humans are
not running around in mazes while we
record their brain activity and so
instead of these theta oscillations we
found these lower frequency waves which
you see here on the top right which is
about three four cycles per second and
so we've wondered for during this time
during these years whether these
findings and rats could translate to
humans and whether our findings in the
laboratory of improving memory within
relation could also translate to the
real world so of course this is really
challenging in the human brain because
as ice
and recording from the human brain
requires that the participant is
stationary and is not moving so
traditional methods that are shown here
such as MRI functional MRI and we keep
pet even recording from the lectures and
patients with epilepsy requires them to
sit still because of motion artifacts
and the other limitation hears of these
techniques and only record Android
stimulates superficial brain areas close
to the surface of the head and can't
reach these deep brain areas such as the
campus or enter animal cortex that we
know are important for episodic memory
the third issue that I already mentioned
before is of the tasks that we use in
laboratory involve two-dimensional
stimuli which are not naturalistic or
ecologically valid and so whether our
findings translate to the real world
that is unclear however we've had a
recent opportunity to take these type of
studies out into the real world and
that's with the development of a new
neural implanted device called the
responsive neurostimulator you could see
here on the top left an example patient
with a electrode that is implanted in
hippocampus deep deep in the brain and
these electrodes are implanted for
treatment of epilepsy and so patients
have these implanted and they record
seizures and stimulate on demand when
the device detects seizure activity to
hopefully prevent the seizure from
occurring now over 2000 participants in
the US have been implanted with these
permanent placed electrodes and so
taking a look at them you wouldn't know
that they have one of these there I'm
shown on the top right is an example
bringing activity you know some data
from this electrode where you can see
these brainwaves and potentially what
we're going to talk about these theta
oscillations to try to bridge findings
with rodents and measure these this type
of activity in the real world while
they're moving around this is the first
time we've been able to record deep in
the brain while a participant is
naturally moving really moving or
and I'll tell you today about some
questions we've been asking to
scientifically investigate how these
regions are important for memory and
whether we can translate some these
findings from rats and from the lab out
into the real world so here I'll show
you a video that shows the set up where
we have a participant with an example a
lecture that you see on the top right
it's implanted we can put scalp EEG
headset or cap sorry on on his head as
well as a VR or AR headset and other
wearables that can help us detect any
kind of motion to synchronize with the
deep brain activities you see a setup
here involves motion capture cameras
I'll be showing two videos here at the
map
so in these videos we see the setup of a
participant with a brain lecture than
Clinton who's navigating through a
virtual environment that he can see on
the VR headset there are motion capture
cameras that are tracking his position
his movement the speed and what he's
seeing is updated in real-time as he's
walking through and during all of this
we can record the brain activity as well
as to move to answers our scientific
questions all of this work that's been
possible in the last few years through
NIH funding required a multidisciplinary
approach to MOOC work and what this
means is that we need to work together
with neuroscientists such as myself as
well as neurosurgeons who work with
these patients and implant electrodes
neurologists who are involved in the
participants treatment and help us to
work with the devices that are implanted
engineers to make all of the wearable
technologies the VR headsets and the
deep brain implant synchronized and able
to work together and as well as
psychologists to help us with designing
the tasks and computer scientists help
us program the tasks in VR and integrate
it with all the wearable technologies
and then we also work with several
industry partners including the
companies that develop the implanted
devices as well as virtual reality
companies and what then companies that
can consult with us on the various
technologies and of course all of us is
made possible through funding the brain
initiative and some other funding
sources as well so this is what the
setup looks like that we've developed we
call it a mobile deep brain recording
and simulation platform there are
several devices that together are used
and carried in a backpack by the
participant to which we can wirelessly
communicate in order to view the deep
brain recordings synchronize it with
other data streams and control at all of
this work is done through patients and
participants the volunteering for these
studies by this work is also cooked
posted online and as a preprint and
including open source code that people
can download so this is what it looks
like the full version where you have
full control real-time recording as well
as programmatic control a wireless
control of the implanted stimulator this
setup is also worn with an augmented
reality headset in this case scalp EEG
cap as well as motion capture suit and
biometric recordings that can record
heart rate respirations and conductance
and various other external external
acquired data we can also do stationary
tasks just like traditional studies have
been done in the past where a
participant can sit down and look at a
computer screen and do tasks in that way
we also have lightweight versions of the
tasks which involve wearing a device
such as this on body and the doubt and
the data cannot be reviewed in real time
in this case but we downloaded every
seven minutes or so
the wearable technologies that we use
like I said include heart rate
respiration skin conductance here and
also integrated with wearable washers as
well as eye tracking pen sets depending
on what you want to do in the particular
study you can also take it outside and
look at deep brain recordings during
realistic behaviors out in the real
world there's a lot of potential here
with this platform to start asking
questions that we haven't been able to
do before in neuroscience because we've
been limited by the immobility of our
participants like I said this papers are
a preprint online and open source code
is available so that other laboratories
can replicate the setup and music
emotions of their interest right so what
can we do with this platform what kind
of questions can we ask well for one we
have the ability now to wirelessly
record and stimulate brain activity
during cream eating behaviour in humans
so when we combine that technology with
virtual reality motion capture and
wearables we can investigate as I said
naturalistic eating behaviors
experimental control and last but not
least we can start shirts for novel
therapies that involved involve deep
brain stimulation or stimulation and
begin to you explore the neural
mechanisms that are affected or that are
involved in these type of treatments for
patients with so my laboratory in
particular had I was interested in
episodic memories I've mentioned before
so we sought out to use this platform to
determine whether for one these
phenomenon that were that were
discovered in rodent studies are in fact
present in humans and this refers to
theta oscillations again these eight
Hertz oscillations that are important
that are thought to be important for
memory and occur in rodents but we do we
do not know B prior to this study
whether they were whether they are
present in humans during naturalistic
behaviour let alone for instance during
movement so are they present during
naturalistic behaviour are they
modulated by movement or they modulated
by memory demands these are all
questions we have not been able to
answer until the development of this
platform and while I'm lastly we decided
to explore whether they are modulated by
one's position in the environment as you
saw in the case of grid cells and place
cells in the rodent and whether in this
case they are modulated in the grid like
pattern similar to the grid cells where
they have a hexagonal geometric pattern
to them across an environment so these
are some of the basic science questions
that we sought out to answer with the
plat one and I'll show you some of those
results
so the first finding was that theta
oscillations do and in fact exist during
movement in the hippocampus of Anna
Lionel cortex similar to the rodent
Tydings
however they're not continuous like they
are in those studies very present in
bounce in you come and go so here just
shows an example motion capture on the
top left of the participant walking
through the room we had them walk around
in circles and straight lines you can
see on the top right the movement
trajectory of an example participant
through the through the environment in
the top middle you just see the speed
distribution so we had them walk fast
we have them watch slow so we had a
variety of speed distributions across
for sighted participants and we also had
a continually blind participant who
navigated with the Coover cane and so
the speed distribution of that
participant is a little bit lower but
also vary quite a bit and what we found
was that movement that it did in fact
modulate the presence of these data
oscillations you can see in the bottom
left 8 Hertz oscillation signal that is
significantly higher during movement
compared to immobility and the bottom
right you can see across time and an
example data trace that these 8 Hertz
signals they come and go and so you see
little hotspots of yellow as they are
moving too fast during periods of fast
movement and then the great race that
shows a higher speed in the beginning
and then towards the right when they
stop moving you see the movement speed
goes down and those 8 Hertz theta
oscillations are less prevalent so this
is of course one example participant we
have characterized this across the
entire group of registrants and we found
that statistically these 8 Hertz beta
oscillations are present but they're
more more prevalent during the fast
movement speeds compared to the slow
with the rodents things and in addition
to the 8 in addition to me 16 Hertz
harmonic that you see with the black
lines doing areas of statistical
significance it was the case for both
sighted participants and the blind
participants that the faster walking
speeds course wanted to more a higher
prevalence of these data oscillations
but overall in the presence of these
oscillations is quite low you look at
the y-axis it's about 10% of the time
when we sighted 30% we find wine which
is much lower than we see in rodents and
so now we're exploring you know why is
this the case that it's so much lower
and what drives the increase in the
prevalence of these data also Asians so
we decided to do a experiment in virtual
reality where
we can control the what the participant
is seeing and viewing and had them to a
memory experiment where they had to in
this video that you see here walk around
and visit various locations that are
outlined as a yellow cylindrical Kol but
they have to learn the location of the
those halos and the order that that
which they are presented and later press
joystick whenever they reach those
positions during a memory recall period
and so here in this video you can see an
example are spent navigating the
environment and learning these various
locations and then having to recall it
later
you
this setup is all during simultaneous
brain recording which again as I
mentioned before has not been possible
up until now so the data we have here is
from an example participant on the right
you see the top-down view of the
locations that they have to learn in
yellow and they're recalled locations in
brown diamonds you could see after
several blocks of learning they do get
better and they improve such that on the
right side in the last block the
positions of the brown diamonds course
on quite nicely two yellow circles and
at the bottom you can see overall
averages across the group where they're
learning the locations over time with
their five watts and their memories in
fact improving on the position and the
order of the so they are learning these
positions and we wanted to next ask
whether this type of memory experiment
could modulate these theta theta
oscillations and whether there's any
kind of spatial modulation in terms of
the participants position can we see any
kind of grid-like activity in this data
and in fact we do see a grid-like
pattern in the data which I'll show you
in a second but just to quickly explain
how this analysis is done based on and
the idea that these grid cells have a
sort of alignment across them in this
pattern you see on the top left where
the peaks of the grid cell firing fields
have fuel walking along their peaks you
should expect a higher level of activity
shown in this or the peach color here
versus the gray areas where you aren't
walking during positions that are not
aligned to the grid cell activity you
should see as high of an activity so
this was the hypothesis effect
hypothesized a shock that you should see
if and track data oscillations are
modulated by a grid-like pattern and in
fact we do see that if we take the data
and split it for positions during which
the participant is walking along the
aligned area of
a grid that pattern versus unaligned in
blue you see a higher amount of theta
activity during the align periods for
every single participant that we took
tested in the study including the blind
participant who did non virtual reality
version of the study and instead did an
auditory task so we found this
I find all participant in a hand
electrodes that you see here shown on
top of the dotted black line so five
electrodes showed this grid like
modulation of finger and these happen to
be in areas that we would expect like
the internal cortex it's a big Yulin it
do not this hexa directional modulation
did not occur for other advanced of
oscillatory activity such as beta or
gamma so it was the victim oscillation
and this effect was stronger after
memory had had had been formed so after
they had learned on the positions of the
environment you can take their peak
sorry their peak slope of their learning
rate and look at the hexa directional
modulation after that point compared to
before three of those participants are
stronger effect after versus before this
one participant who didn't show the
effect did not perform that well on his
tasks and so their their learning rate
was not quite as great and so that made
the confounding the results there but it
was evidence for suggested islands that
memory could modulate this grid-like
modulation of theta activity and so we
then wanted to look at other effects
corresponding to theta activity across
the environment another interesting
finding whereby the position of the
participant in the room modulated the
theta activity in that the closer they
were to a boundary the stronger the
theta activity was so proximity to and
the environmental boundary of the room
which in this case is the wall modulated
theta activity to show you had higher
thing activity when they're closer to
the walls compared to when they were
farther on the bottom left shows in exam
all from one participant and when the
right is the average across all of the
participants in this study where we see
stronger theta power or boundary
locations compared to inner
environmental locations and we also see
this for the gamma frequency and not
just for the low-frequency dancer so
here is another case where position in
the environment can modulate think the
power and so the last question to ask is
does memory also modulate this finding
and I'll show you that in a second but
just to make sure a couple other
questions we asked whether this effect
was moderated by movement and it turns
out it was not and so this effect
occurred also during periods of standing
only shown in the middle where you have
stronger theta power or boundary
locations compared to inner locations
even if they're just ending still and
they're not moving and on the on the
right side you see the effect also for
areas where they're near weatheritt
where there are not near a target
location to be learned so this is not
dependent on movement as shown in the
middle plot and it's not dependent on
their position at a learned target
location which is which are too critical
analyses to do to try to answer what
really is modulating this theta activity
with regards to boundaries so the last
question I mentioned was business effect
which it's occurs in which occurs in
every single participant like shown here
on the top P 1 through 5 we have
stronger beta active need for boundary
locations compared to inner business
effect modulated by memory and it turns
out it is so when participants are
looking for target locations shown in
green you see the boundary effect you do
not see it there when they are walking
to the walls in the case of the orange
so we have them in this task
look for target locations in green in
the center you see in the center the
bottom left picture but we also have
them just walk to various wall locations
we had a colored paper stimuli on the
walls when we we just have them walk to
those locations so there was no real
memory demand
in that case and we found that this
boundary modulate the theta actually
only occurred during periods when they
were searching for the hidden targets
and not when they were just on walking
to the wall locations in this in this
case we call this no target search and
we can see that broken up in the right
panel on the bottom we see increased
beta for boundary locations for target
search periods and not for the no target
experience so altogether all of these
findings suggest that memory can
modulate in theta oscillations when
these data oscillations can be modulated
by naturalistic walking behaviors
movement and position within an
environment close to boundaries and also
modulated by a grid-like pattern so
summarizing these results high frequency
beta oscillations exists in humans
during naturalistic behaviors there's a
higher prevalence of these oscillation
oscillations during fast walking
movements perhaps related to a higher
cognitive demand but you didn't talk too
much about here but can discuss more
people are interested and this theta
activity is modulated in a grid-like
pattern it's more it's stronger after a
memory is formed and it is also
modulated by proximity to a boundary and
again this effect is also stronger
during periods of high memory Canyon and
is independent of movement so altogether
we've been able to start to translate
findings from the rodent and our
laboratory based studies into the real
world the next steps are of course to
see whether stimulation can improve
memory in the real world and we can do
that because this platform allows for
stimulation on the man and we can start
to ask whether we can improve memory in
the real world and hopefully contribute
to future therapies for memory disorders
I'd like to thank the team that did all
of this work in my lab postdocs and
graduate students programmers and
research assistants and we all come from
various backgrounds in terms of training
and education so it really truly is a
multidisciplinary approach with
neuroscience engineering psychology and
your science and
I want to thank our research
participants who volunteered our alumni
from the lab who all saw autism who
helped a lot with all of these studies
and the various other collaborators as I
mentioned before and funding sources so
with that I will take any questions if
there are any and thank you all for
listening